[Music]
before he assembled The
Avengers sorry and dismantled the SN
verse Jos Weeden changed the face of
television and we're still paying the
price for it today stop Buffy the
Vampire Slayer the
series welcome to Sunny Dale a Gilmore
Girl setting with a deadwood body
count this California Hamlet happens to
sit on top of a hellmouth but unlike
Fresno this one is either a massive Cape
that causes a
sinkhole or is made of
Vibes cuz hellmouth isn't just a plot
convenience that spits out Monsters of
the week it's also n that's it it's a
literal plot
hole here to defend Murder Town USA is
Buffy Summers a reluctant Child Soldier
dates are things normal girls have she's
the latest in a long and storyed line of
sexy benh hel sings but Buffy yes Buffy
it's Buffy she's Buffy what kind of name
is Buffy we'll team up with Giles this
hboi Frasier Crane I've made up my mind
so have I I made up M first Buffy's
mentor likes to watch and spends the
entirety of the series either giving
Exposition or getting
[Music]
head wake up how many times have you
been knocked out anyway In fairness it's
easier to sound smart when you're 40
year-old who only hangs out with
teenagers Gnar of course yeah you kids
are too young to know about Gnar back in
the the day he was
the together they're joined by a
veritable upn's worth of mildly dated
teen archetypes there's Willow whose
friends Were Somehow surprised when she
followed the nerd to Wick to lesbian
pipeline she's gay but but but we don't
gay oh it's magic weed plus there's
Xander a literal Marty stew author
insert Xander was obviously um based on
me the sort of guy that all the girls
want to be best friends with in high
school who gets the best lines and makes
with the hottest
girls take a sh love oh
yeah what you dreaming
of
take Spike the bad boy who became an
ally after stalking Buffy building a
robot real doll who resembled Buffy and
sexually assaulting Buffy so lovely and
Undead Dreamboat Angel the latest guy to
use vampirism to get around the age Gap
discourse I mean come on it's kind of
obvious what he's up to the second she
graduates he's out there faster than
DiCaprio do you want more of that one
Jos Weeden I'm being mean in a cute way
bit 1 1800 I'm dating a skanky hoe
you're not a third wheel well
technically speaking you're a fifth
wheel let me answer that question with a
headbutt or he describing something
messed up in a cute way bit party in my
eyce socket and everyone's invited did
you try looking inside the sofa in Hell
between me and my evil self I have
double guilt coupons well prepare to
regret your decision in a show that
makes you yearn for the subtlety of his
uncredited X-Men script do you know what
happens to a toad when it's struck by
lightning the same thing that happens to
everything else look there's nothing
wrong with Jos being a nepo baby or even
a nepo grandbaby so long as you come up
with a few actual fresh jokes I don't
know think of something cool tell them I
said it or hey stick to what works o
pancakes could go in bellies love the
old WB Network well if you did it
wouldn't have become the CW but Buffy
has all the WB stuff you loved like
early appearances by stars who would
later get mega famous cameos by already
famous people just here for some funes
random musical acts in the team club oh
hell yeah is that Dishwalla wait no that
was Charmed speaking of remember when
your favorite show suddenly had a
musical
episode there's a good chance they were
inspired by Buffy sorry but that's still
better than using Buffy to launch your
music career like all the other actors
did Behind Blue
Eyes and hey only one of them wrote an O
to the toes of an underage Michelle
trenburg
why is it always feet so Di dive back in
to a charming bit of late '90s Arcana
James fader he needs to call me stupid
video store if the apocalypse comes beat
me when all TV and makeup Prosthetics
just make actors look like Klingons and
kids were so abandoned by their parents
they could literally trigger the
apocalypse unnoticed Mrs
Summers good she's gone in a landmark
series that Define the team culture of
its era and exclusively its era it's a
Soma kickstarting wave after wave of ya
series about how growing up is kind of
like fighting a mystical war against
necromancers you're not going to change
you're not going to change you're not
going to change oh cuz puberty causes
changes and makes you feel like a
monster how did I just get
this
starring I Know What You Did Last
Summers help my son is a nerd this one
time at w Camp Professor Dumbledore
Cordelia the teenage B silly Idol nice
guys diminish last like and dope Jos
weeden's brawl housee demon player
kimetsu no yba From Dusk Till Dawn and
Ethan quippy the vampire
seral look is it a coincidence that the
best episode is the one where no one can
talk let's see Jos quip his way through
that
he did it the madman actually did
it in every generation there is a chosen
one she alone will stand against the
vampires the demons and the forces of
Darkness she is the Slayer it's
Halloween everybody's entitled to one
good scare
here